let me ask you a question you're
probably not going to want to answer
because uh
you're focused on the mathematics of
things and mathematics can't answer the
why questions but
let me ask you anyway
do you think there's meaning to this
whole thing
what do you think is the meaning of life
why are we here
i don't i don't know yeah i
was thinking about this so the um
it did occur one interesting
thing about that question is that you
don't you know so i have
this life in mathematics and this life
in physics and and i see
some of my physicist colleagues you know
kind of
seem to be people are often asking them
what's the meaning of life when they're
writing books about the meaning of life
and teaching courses about the meaning
of life and but then i realized that no
one ever asked my mathematician
colleagues
nobody ever asked mathematicians but
yeah that's fine so i i i
yeah
everybody just kind of assumes okay well
you people are studying about that i see
whatever you're doing it's
maybe very interesting but it's clearly
not going to tell me anything useful
about the meaning of my life and i'm
afraid a lot of my point of view is that
if people realized how little difference
there was between what the
mathematicians are doing and what a lot
of these theoretical physicists are
doing they would they might understand
that
it's a bit misguided to look for
deep insight into the meaning of life
from
fro
from many theoretical physicists it's
not uh
they you know they're they're people and
they have they may have interesting
things to say about this you're right
they have they know a lot about physical
reality about
about
and sometimes about metaphysics about
what
is is real of this kind but um
you're also
to my mind i think you're also making a
bit of a mistake that you're you're
looking to uh
i mean i'm very very aware that you know
i've led a very
pleasant and fairly privileged existence
of a fairly
without many challenges of different
kinds of a certain kind and and um
i i'm really not in no way the kind of
person that
a lot of people who are looking for to
try to understand
in some meaning of life in the sense of
the challenges that they're facing in
life uh i can't really i'm really the
wrong person for you to be asking about
this whoa
if struggle is somehow a thing that's
core to meaning yeah perhaps
mathematicians are just quietly the ones
who are
most equipped to answer that question if
in fact the creation or at least
experiencing beauty
is uh
is is at the core of the meaning of life
because it seems like mathematics is the
methodology but which you can most
purely explore beautiful things
right yeah
so in some sense maybe we should talk to
mathematicians more
yeah yeah maybe but but the uh
unfortunately i think you know people do
have a somewhat correct perception that
what
these people are doing every day is is
pretty far removed from anything
yeah from from what's kind of close to
what i'm
what i do every day and what my typical
concerns are so you may learn something
very interesting by talking to
mathematicians but it's a
it's probably not gonna be you're
probably not gonna get what you were
hoping
so when you put the pen and paper down
and you're not thinking about physics
and you're not thinking about
mathematics and you just get to breathe
in the air and look around you and
realize that you're going to die one day
you know you think about that
um
your ideas will live on but you the
human
not not not especially much but
certainly i've been getting getting
older i'm now 64 years old you start to
realize well there's
probably less ahead than there was
behind and so you start to
that starts to become you know wait what
do i think about that maybe i should
actually
get serious about getting some things
done which
which i may not have which i may
otherwise not have time to do which i
didn't see this didn't seem to be a
problem when i was younger but um
that's the main i think the main way in
which that thought occurs
but it doesn't uh you know the stoics
are big on this meditating on mortality
helps you
more intensely appreciate the beauty
when you do experience it
i suppose that's true but it's not yeah
it's not
not something i've spent
a lot of time trying but um but yeah
day to day you just enjoyed the positive
mathematics just enjoy yeah or
our life in general life is
have a
perfectly pleasant life and enjoy enjoy
it and
often think wow this is i think things
are
i'm really enjoying those things are
going well
yeah life is pretty amazing yeah i think
you and i are pretty lucky we get to uh
live on this nice little earth yeah with
a nice little comfortable climate and we
get to have this
nice little podcast conversation peter
i'm a big fan of your blog
i'm a big fan of your work
and uh thank you so much for spending
your valuable time with me today in this
conversation thank you glad thank you
thank you
you